I would have lunch with my grandfather
three times a week so he was 90 old guy
so I would go to the nursing home and
listening to him talk about the regrets
that you had in life it's so much more
painful to watch someone who has no
options left when I left Baltimore one
of the sad parts is I was one of the
only people that kind of like kept him
lucid and after that no one really
visited him no one really did anything
and so I think he he just rolled
downhill I think the lunches might have
been the only thing that he looked
forward to he would repeat the same
lessons and he always used to say he's
like you have two hands and one brain
use them